-Good evening. I'm Seth Meyers,
and this is "Late Night."
we hope you're doing well.
And now, let's get to the news.
President Biden today
outlined the next phase
of his administration's
pandemic response,
and it's tough, but fair.
White House officials
have asked multiple members
of military academy boards
who were appointed
by former President Trump
to resign, including
former White House
Press Secretary Sean Spicer
and Kellyanne Conway.
Spicer is currently on the board
of the Naval Academy,
and Conway is on the board
of the Academy of the
French Cavalry?
After Virginia removed
a 21-foot statue
of Confederate general
Robert E. Lee
from the state capital,
former President Trump
released a statement saying
the U.S. would have succeeded
in Afghanistan
if Lee had been in command.
Dude, he got his ass kicked
in Virginia.
What do you think
the problem was?
Too many trees?
Former New Jersey governor
Chris Christie spoke tonight
at the Ronald Reagan Library
about the future
of the Republican Party.
I guess it's always good
to get an outside opinion.
Taliban yesterday announced
a ban on all protests
and slogans that do not have the
interim government's approval --
hence Pizza Hut's new slogan
in Afghanistan.
Donald Trump Jr. claimed
in a recent Instagram post
that former President Trump
"took more crap
than any other president
times about 1,000."
Wow, 1,000 -- that's more than
four score and seven.
North Korean leader Kim Jong-un
is receiving attention online
after appearing in a military
parade earlier today
looking noticeably slimmer.
This first reported
in North Korea's
"Help Us Weekly."
In honor of Disney World's
50th anniversary,
McDonald's has announced
it will release
50 new Happy Meal toys
that feature Disney characters.
50? You're really digging deep.
"I got Mickey!
What did you get?"
"Um, the dead lady from 'Up.'"
Netflix has announced
that a new season of
"The Great British Baking Show"
will premiere later this month.
"Oh, thank God," said
overscheduled therapists.
Authorities in Florida
recently arrested a woman
who allegedly drove a golf cart
through an active
police standoff
while naked and intoxicated --
Which sounds insane,
but, come on -- it's Florida.
They only caught her
because she crashed into
another naked woman
in a golf cart.
And finally, Mercedes Benz
is set to reveal
new electric cars next week
at the Munich Auto Show
as well as a car
that parks itself
across two handicap spots.
And that, you guys,
was a monologue.